I would say there's two clear signs that
would indicate when a conflict is about
to become a negative conflict for the
team or for the business the first sign
that a conflict is going to become a
negative force in your team is if the
emotions are starting to escalate people
are getting angry if they're getting
upset this is a sign that the conflict
is going to become personal is going to
become distracting from task performance
the second sign that a conflict is going
to be destructive for a team is if
people are fighting about things so they
actually don't really care about it
shouldn't be that important so if you're
fighting about something very silly
about what time to meet or who's going
to do what often these types of
conflicts are then used for people to
fight about bigger issues be it status
concerns leadership issues questions of
respect as if you're fighting about
something that you just it doesn't make
sense why this is such a big issue it
often means that your team is in trouble
and this is a destructive conflict and
they need to take a step back and figure
out what the real issues are and go from
there
conflicts generally start with one
person who's listening to a group
discussion and thanks gee I really don't
agree with what this means said here I
should say something so the person
expresses conflict and other people on
the team had the choice to reflect on
that and to offer the feedback to agree
or disagree generally one person will
offer feedback to what the person said
so you think we should take strategy X
well actually I think we should take
strategy Y at this point you have an
interpersonal conflict between two
people on the team that of five team
members could be sitting there watching
and deciding whether or not they should
choose to engage or not conflicts at
this stage generally are the most
positive for team performance because of
two people engaging are engaged because
of authentic interest in the issue and
differences in opinion or information
that need to be reconciled however as a
conflict starts to escalate and to grow
and to evolve more members members may
not always join for reasons due to the
question being fought about they could
join because they get emotional the
people are starting to yell or to get
angry and they also get emotional could
also be that they're helping political
alliances their boss or their friend or
so when they're close to is involved in
the conflict and they feel may need to
join it to support them this is the
second phase of conflict and where
subgroups start to form and when the sub
groups involved in the conflict again it
intensifies it escalates and it's more
likely to become personal and
destructive than the initial conflict
between the two people who had just
different pieces of information and as
these subgroups start to fight with one
another over time any remaining members
that weren't involved in the conflict
have no choice they're going to be
sucked in as well and then you have a
true team brawl which is not going to be
a good thing for team performance
if a manager detects a conflict in the
team the first thing that the manager
should do is to identify what's being
discussed and who's evolved and why so
if he sees two members or she sees two
members discussing an issue this very
related to the task and the member seem
to be engaging in this debate because
they want to make the team better as a
manager this is a conflict that you
should allow to go out if there's let it
play out and to see where they come to
in this conflict however if the manager
notes that the conflict is personal or
emotional or sebat issues that are not
so important such as about the process
this is a conflict that you should cut
off and try to resolve offline talk to
the members individually try to get them
on the same page again so that be the
first step is to understand what they're
fighting about what their motivations
are and then to deal with that so task
conflicts again are the most productive
form of conflict in teams and there's
three other forms of conflict that can
occur in teams and are generally likely
to hurt team performance these three
destructive types of conflict in teams
are process conflicts relationship
conflicts and Status conflicts process
conflicts are conflicts about the
logistics of day-to-day work in teams of
what time we're going to meet who's
going to do what what responsibilities
each person should have these conflicts
interestingly have been shown to be the
most negative form of conflict that can
occur in teams the reason being is that
these conflicts often represent
underlying issues in the team that if
you're going to fight about roles and
responsibilities is often because you
care about your status or your prestige
in the team but you're unwilling to say
that so then you choose indirectly to
choose the best responsibility for
yourself to gain prestige over your
teammates let's make these these types
of conflicts particularly dangerous
relationship conflicts are another
negative form of conflict in teams
relationship conflicts are about
personality clashes differences in
political beliefs people who just don't
get along these conflicts have always
been shown to be negative for team
performance and are best avoided if you
can the last type of conflict that's
been more recently pointed out in the
literature is status conflicts are
conflicts about the relative respect
that people have from one another within
the team about the hierarchy about the
rank order these types of conflicts are
especially prevalent and higher level
teams in the organizations or change
that people really care about status and
power so management teams
boards of directors etc these conflicts
are particularly difficult to work with
and often negative for performance
because people often don't voice them
directly is indirect behaviors is
engaging in process conflicts to claim a
choice responsibility to improve your
status as a gauge in a relationship
conflicts to derogate somebody to again
prove improve your own position and
because your status conflicts are so
insidious they're very difficult to
catch and very difficult to resolve as
if there's any way to get the team on
the same page to avoid status issues in
the first place and matter to be well
advised to do that one of the solutions
in the literature that's been looked at
then is how do you help virtual team
it's given the virtual teams have more
issues with conflict the face-to-face
teams and one main solution is to make
sure that you have a face-to-face
kickoff when you start working together
with a virtual team this is really
critical to give team members a few days
together to get to know one another so
they have a context and understanding of
the relationship and of the person in
case they do have a conflict over email
or over the phone they know how to make
sense of it to make the right
attributions rather than taking things
personally
if conflict isn't managed and isn't
dealt with and it transforms into a
negative form of conflict be a process
conflict relationship conflict status
conflict it can tear it into pieces
there's been research that shows that
conflict leads to psychosomatic
complaints people get burnout they get
depressed they leave the company and the
teams eventually can dissolve so the
dangers of not resolving conflict are
huge is something that managers really
do need to take seriously in the daily
life of their teams is to monitor their
conflicts and prevent them from getting
to that point
my top 3 tips for managing conflict and
organization include knowing what people
are fighting about why they're fighting
and what are their emotions while
they're fighting so to discuss each of
these 3 points in a little bit more
detail first understand what they're
fighting about what's the topic of the
conflict is it about the goals of the
team or is it about something that's not
likely to help your team so much such as
questions of logistics interpersonal
tensions status concerns etc so
recognize what the topic of the conflict
is and make choices accordingly secondly
understand the motivations of why people
are engaging in conflict is what they're
fighting about the real issue are their
issues under the surface so people are
trying to indirectly raise in another
manner so just you know are they
engaging in a process conflict about
what time to meet as a way to further
their own status position in the team
and to have strategies ready to resolve
these underlying issues so recognize why
they're engaging and make sure you deal
with the conflict at that level rather
than necessarily at the surface level
finally to look at the emotions and to
monitor the emotions carefully during
conflicts in the minute that members
start to become emotional to be upset to
raise their voices this conflict is no
longer going to be good for performance
and the team needs to take a break you
need to step in and resolve at one and
what members individually or find a way
out of the situation before it escalates
out of control
you